hi guys I'm Ralph from simply learn and
today we will be talking about as your
certifications now before we go into a
little bit of detail let's first talk
about what exactly is and as your
certification so the as your
certifications are actually examinations
that are provided by Microsoft these
help you validate how well you
understand the concepts of azure and how
well you can work with it these are
basically badges of honor that you can
show off these also play a very
important role when it comes to hiring
or promotion you are obviously more
likely to be selected if you are a
certified professional now these
certifications cover a wide range of
domains and these certifications also
work towards a specified role for
example you have certifications that
help you become a Solutions Architect or
an as your administrator or as your
developer now if you need a little more
convincing as to why you should be
taking up and as your certification here
are a few more as your provides powerful
data and artificial intelligence
services that help create intelligent
applications as your has more than
hundred services that span a wide range
of domains they also help satisfy a
great number of requirements more than
eighty percent of the fortune 500
companies use Microsoft Azure for their
cloud computing requirements not to
mention these organizations that used
Microsoft products can actually avail an
enterprise agreement that gives them
discounts on Azure services and finally
as your provide services across 42
regions in the world which is more than
any other cloud service provider does in
the market right now now let's talk
about Azure certifications so it's
highly likely that you've heard of
Microsoft more popular certifications
the seven zero five three two seven zero
five three three and seven zero five
three five but Microsoft is changing its
approach towards certifications
Microsoft's new certifications aim to
make the individual fall into a
particular role for example as your
administrator associate as your
developer associate as your solutions
architect and the azure DevOps engineer
expert this is what Microsoft introduced
in the ignite conference that took place
on September 24th there Microsoft
introduced new certifications that fall
onto the ASAT category now to become an
azure administrator associate you need
to have the a set one
certification or the Microsoft Azure
infrastructure and deployment and the
ACE at one zero one or Microsoft Azure
integration and security to become an
azure developer you need the ACE at 200
which is the Microsoft Azure developer
core solution certification and is it
2:01 or the Microsoft Azure developer
advance solution certification finally
to become a Solutions Architect you will
need the ACE at 300 or the Microsoft
Azure architect technologies and the is
a three zero one or the Microsoft Azure
architect design now these were all
introduced on September 24th when the
Ignite conference took place now the old
certifications the 5 3 2 5 3 3 & 5 3 5
will be discontinued from the 31st of
December 2018 so what happens to the
people who've actually done it that's
why Microsoft includes the A's at 1 0 2
2 0 2 & 3 0 2 transition certifications
now we will talk about that in a little
bit so now let's go into all of the new
certifications in detail so now let's
talk about exam is at 100 or the
Microsoft Azure infrastructure and
deployment certification so this is
basically part 1 of 2 when it comes to
becoming and as your administrator this
costs 165 u.s. dollars now let's have a
look at the syllabus for this exam
some of the domains that you need to
prepare for and their approximate
weightages so first off you need to know
how you can manage as your subscriptions
and resources this involves managing
subscriptions analyzing how resources
are being used and how they're consumed
and managing other resource groups
secondly you have implementing and
managing storage you need to know how
you can create and configure storage
accounts how you can import and export
data to Azure configures your files and
how you can implement as your backup
then you have deploying and managing
virtual machines you need to know how
you can create and configure virtual
machines for Windows or Linux you need
to know how you can automate deployment
of virtual machines you need to know how
you can manage Azure virtual machines
and manage Virtual Machine backups then
you need to know how you can configure
and manage virtual networks you need to
be able to create connectivity between
virtual networks how you can implement
and manage virtual networking configure
name the solution the group's finally
you need to know how you can manage
identities you need to be able to manage
as your active directories and you need
to know how you can implement
manage hybrid identities the next step
in becoming an azure administrator is to
do the easy one zero one or the
Microsoft Azure integration and security
certification the ACE at one zero one or
the Microsoft Azure integration and
security certification goes into a
little more detail when it comes to
becoming and as your administrator the
certification cost hundred and sixty
five US dollars now let's have a look at
some of the important topics that you
need to know for this examination so
let's have a look at some of the
portions that you need to be well-versed
with to perform well in this examination
first up we have evaluating and
performing several migrations to us yer
then we have implementing and managing
application services which involves
configuring several is computing
managing app service plans and managing
app services then you have implementing
advanced virtual networking that
involves implementing application load
balancing implementing as your load
balancer monitoring and managing
networking integrating the on-premise
network with the azure network and so on
and finally securing identities you need
to be able to implement a multi-factor
authentication manage a role based
control system implementing as your
active directories and privileged
Identity Management so after you are
done with is at 101 zero one you become
a Microsoft certified as your
administrator associate but what happens
to the people who already done the
implementing Microsoft Azure
infrastructure solution certification or
the seven zero five three three it's for
these people that Microsoft has the ACE
at 1:02 or the Microsoft Azure
administrator certification transition
now this examination that costs 99 US
dollars contains concepts from both AZ
at 100 and is at 101 and this exam is
only valid for people who already
completed the seven zero five three
three certification now if you have
completed the seven zero five three
three I suggest you do this transition
certification immediately as this will
be discontinued by Microsoft by the 31st
of March 2019 now let's have a look at
how you can become a Microsoft certified
as your developer associate to do this
you need to complete two certifications
the a is at 200 or the Microsoft Azure
developer Koh solution certification and
the ASA 201 or the Microsoft Azure
developer advance solution certification
so now let's have a look at the A's at
200 now this certification
is part one of two when it comes to
becoming and as your developer associate
it costs hundred sixty five US dollars
now this examination is in its beta
phase which means that unlike normal
examinations where you get your results
as soon as you finish the examination
this exam will take at least one or two
weeks before you can get your result the
questions are still being worked on and
improved upon there's also a limitation
to how many people can take the exam at
the moment now let's have a look at some
of the portions that you need to prepare
for for this examination you need to be
able to select an appropriate cloud
technology solution based on your
requirements this may involve a compute
solution integration or a storage
solution next you need to be able to
develop for cloud storage which involves
developing solutions that involve
storage tables file storage relational
databases and so much more you need to
be able to create platform-as-a-service
solutions which involves creating web
applications mobile applications app
services server less functions and so
much more and finally you need to be
able to secure cloud solutions you need
to implement authentication access
control and secure data solutions now
microsoft recommends that you have at
least a year of experience working with
microsoft's you're creating applications
with Azure tools and technologies while
at the same time having a solid
understanding of all the phases of
software development now let's have a
look at the next step to becoming a
Microsoft Azure developer you need to do
the ACE at 2:01 or the Microsoft Azure
developer advanced solution
certification now let's have a look at
that now this examination is also in its
beta phase and will move to its final
version in the next few months as of now
it cost hundred and sixty five US
dollars now let's have a look at some of
the portions that you need to prepare
for for this examination you need to
know how you can develop phone as your
cloud model you need to develop for auto
scaling develop for long running tasks
distributed transaction and so much more
you need to know how you can implement
cloud integration solutions like
managing API is using API management
configure message based integration
architecture to develop an application
message model and so much more and
finally you need to know how you can
develop as yours cognitive services
bought an IOT solutions you need to be
able to create and integrate BOTS create
and implement IOT solutions and to
integrate the azure cognitive services
in an application after you're done
all of this you become a Microsoft
certified as your developer associate
now let's talk about easy to zero to now
this is a transition examination for
anyone who's done 7 0 5 3 2 or
developing Microsoft Azure solution
certification now just like the other
transition certification this cost 99 US
dollars and it is in its beta phase now
this is accessible for only people who
have done the 7 0 5 3 do and is
available only for a limited period of
time this will be discontinued from the
31st of March 2019
this has concepts that have been
included in both is at 200 and is a 201
concepts like developing for cloud
storage creating platform as a service
solutions securing cloud solutions
developing for an azure cloud model
implementing cloud integration solutions
developing a machine learning and IOT
solutions now after you're done with
this you can become a Microsoft
certified as your developer associate
now let's find out how you can become a
Microsoft certified as your solutions
architect expert for this you need to do
two certifications the age at 300 and
the age at 301 now let's have a look at
is at 300 which is the Microsoft Azure
architect technology certification now
the ASA 300 is still in its beta phase
and cost 165 dollars this is part 1 of 2
for becoming a Microsoft certified as
your solutions architect expert now
let's talk about some of the topics that
you need to prepare for for this
examination you need to know how you can
deploy and configure infrastructure
which involves analyzing the resource
utilization consumption creating and
configuring storage accounts creating
and configuring virtual machines for
Windows and Linux automating deployment
of virtual machines and so much more
then you need to know how you can
implement workloads and security like
migrating servers to s your configure
surveillance computing implementing
application load balancing managing role
based access control implementing
multi-factor authentication and so on
then you need to architect cloud
technology solutions you need to be able
to select appropriate compute solutions
integrate solution storage solutions you
need to be able to create and deploy
applications like for example creating
web applications using past create an
application or service that runs on
service fabric design and develop
applique
that run and containers and so on then
you need to implement authentications
and secure data and finally you need to
develop for the cloud which means you
need to know how you can develop long
running tasks configure message based
integration develop for auto scaling
implement distributed transactions and
so on
now this certification does require you
to be having expert level skills in at
least as your administration as your
development or DevOps you also need to
have experience with the various steps
and IT operations like networking
virtualization security and so on this
is because the Azure Solutions Architect
play a very important role of advising
stakeholders to convert their
requirements into scalable secure and
reliable solutions so now the next step
is to do the is at 3:01
or the Microsoft Azure architect design
certification now let's have a look at
that now like all the other
certifications this cost one hundred and
sixty-five dollars and is still in its
beta phase this is the final step in
becoming and Azure solutions architect
expert now let's have a look at some of
the topics that you need to prepare for
for this certification firstly you need
to know how you can determine workload
requirements you need to know how to
gather information and requirements to
optimize the consumption strategy and
the design name auditing and monitoring
strategy you need to design for identity
and security like design identity
management design authentication
authorization and a monitoring strategy
for identity and security then you need
to know how you can design a data
platform solution you need to design a
data management strategy a data
protection strategy document data flows
and so on then you need to design a
business continuity strategy for example
to design a site recovery strategy
ensure that there's high availability
design a disaster recovery strategy and
to design a data archiving strategy then
you need to design for deployment
migration and integration you need to
design deployments design migrations and
design an API integration strategy and
finally you need to know how you can
design a storage strategy a compute
strategy networking strategy and so on
after you done with all of this you
become a Microsoft certified as your
solutions architect expert so what about
those people who have already done the
7:05 three
five or the architecting Microsoft Azure
solution certification that's where the
easy at 3:02 comes in now the ACA at
3:02 is a transition certification which
cost 99 US dollars this acts as a
replacement for anyone who's done the
7-0 535 certification now this is again
in its beta phase but will last only
till March 31st 2019 now if you finish
the certification you get to become an
azure Solutions Architect expert now
this consists of topics included in both
Asia 300 and 301 concepts like
determining workload requirements
designing for identity and security
designing a business continuity strategy
implementing workloads in security
implementing authentication and securing
data and developing for the club now
what we've mentioned in this video are
the most important as your
certifications now there are older
certifications but will not cover them
because we will be focusing on the more
important role based examinations that
have been introduced recently so how can
simply learn helped you as you've
noticed the Microsoft certifications are
going through a major overhaul and
simply learn is reflecting those changes
so will be very soon coming up with
courses that match the new updated
content but as of now there's one thing
that remains unchanged which is the
Microsoft Azure fundamentals
simply learn provides a course which
goes through all of the major concepts
and services that Azure has to offer
like the Azure management tools virtual
machines web applications how you can
create and configure virtual networks
cloud storage managing the Azure Active
Directory and so on and with that we've
reached the end of another video I hope
you guys found this informative and
helpful thank you for watching and stay
tuned for more from simpler hi there if
you like this video subscribe to the
simple learn YouTube channel and click
here to watch similar videos to nerd up
and get certified click here